hello and welcome to another great
episode of Google developers live my
name is Arun Nagarajan with the google
apps developer relations team and it's
actually a really special episode we
have a great partner here hello sign and
they're going to walk us through a great
add-on that they've built for Google
Docs before we get started they I want
them to do stem cell O'Meara from he'll
assign one the co-founders and I'm
Joseph Walla and I'm also one of the
co-founders awesome we have the co
fibers of a great hello sign here keep
telling a little bit about your roles
within the company and what you work on
yeah so I'm the CEO neyo CTO and I do
works on all the technical side and I
work on the business side awesome
awesome so for the folks that don't know
hollow side can you tell a bit about
what Hilary does and what some of your
products focus on yeah definitely so
hellosign is the easiest way to sign
documents online traditionally whenever
you had to sign a document you'd have to
print sign and scan the document and so
what we did is we made it so you could
sign it all from your computer you can
sign it digitally or from your phone as
well and what was exciting about this
specific add-on is that also in you can
sign it directly from Google Docs I
suppose we can talk about that in a
little bit yeah absolutely yeah that's
great so before we dig into some of the
details of the a daughter let's do a
quick demo let's take a look at what it
looks like and then kind of dissect some
of the internals of it all right let's
go to the demo so you kind of have two
main workflows here and one of them is
you know you need to sign a document and
you need to send it to someone so for
example maybe you have an offer letter
and you need to send it out and you know
it's nice to sign the offer letter
before you send it so in Google Docs you
know you can pull up hello signed signed
document shows the sidebar and in this
case who needs to signs just me so once
you pull that up bill polling save
signatures you have from your hellosign
account in this case I have Harry Truman
Harry my signature so you can just drag
and drop that straight into the document
sign it right there it's really great
really easy functionality you know
resize it make a little little nicer and
there you go you have a signed document
if you don't have any save signatures
you can draw a new signature so that
will pop up a modal where you know with
a html5 canvas you know you can add your
signature and you can save that drag it
back on and then you can email it out as
a PDF if you don't want to share an
editable google doc with the person so
then the the other flow really leverages
hellosign and our functionality about
getting other people to sign so in this
case maybe you have an NDA and you need
your partner to sign NDA
so in this case we just need someone
else to sign so we're going to choose
just others so in this case what we're
doing is we're processing the document
on our side converting it to a format
that we can display to other people and
once that's ready we should say continue
and this is going to pull up take you
over to hello sign and you can you can
type in who needs a sign this can be
multiple people in this case we'll just
do one person that needs a sign so i'll
just do you know plus John you can also
see see people as well so I'll set their
continued and then your document just as
it was in Google Docs is pulled up here
and then you can specify you know where
people need to sign maybe they need to
fill in things maybe they need to date
things so you know this case was just
have this person filling their name and
then let's have them add a signature so
easy as that and you hit continue and
here you can tell them what the document
is give them some instructions so please
sign in return
and then you're done easy is that your
back reading so you started your
authoring process in Google Docs a
formatted it the way you wanted it and
then you kicked it off into hellosign
yeah and great thing about this is if
you also integrate with our drive
integration yeah once this gets signed
on their side they'll be automatically
synced back great to drive so it's your
tying all the add-ons and integrations
together yeah one of the great things
about the Google platform awesome that's
really awesome thank you very much for
that demo so tell me a little bit about
some of the technical pieces what are
some of the interesting points about the
integration are there anything that you
found surprisingly great to use or
challenging yes so one of the things I
was really great for us was being able
to do the drag and drop of a signature
Google it's basically built in
functionality that you guys have
provided us with so that was that was
great in terms of kind of how we built
it we leverage a lot of our API we have
a probably accessible API so a lot of
that was already built involving around
us fetching the signatures that are
associated with the person's account and
sending the document out for someone
else to sign when you launch this out on
what are some of the interesting metrics
you'll be paying attention to what will
be success for you yeah so we always
look at three different metrics one is
just some top of funnel growth so how
many new users are coming in second is
user activity and then the third is
monetization so how many paid plans are
signing up so it's one we um I mean
we've done like multiple Google
integrations now we've integrated with
gmail Drive Google Apps and this will be
our fourth one and usually when we
compare all these numbers to like you
know people who just come to the site
and sign up usually it's a lot better
like people are generally more engaged
usually they upgrade more so all those
key metrics that we look for are usually
quite good when we do integrations
that's great thank you very much for
coming into the studio and walking us
through your process and your your ad on
itself and good luck with the lunch yeah
thanks for having us thank you shouldn't
thank you
you